technology is often presented as a
genius boffin in some backroom who has a
simply marvelous idea and then manages
to get this idea made and here we have
the microprocessor a great benefit to
mankind and anybody that stands in its
way is standing in the way of progress
well in all the cases that I can think
of the technology is presented as though
it is going to liberate people from all
the boring routine back-breaking tasks
that have been engaged in and the
impression is usually given that this
will mean that they'd be free to use a
creativity to the full to satisfying
worthwhile thoughtful jobs the
microprocessor and the ensuing computer
revolution hold the promise of shorter
working weeks more leisure time and an
increasingly affluent society all this
coupled with cheaper international
travel will allow us to explore our
world more fully seeing that life is
rich with the possibilities of enjoyment
from the most basically physical to the
cultural artistic and creative so that's
one feature of our community of the
future will be a center for human
achievement a building where people can
make a choice where they can be matched
by computer with the best outlet for
their abilities people millions and
millions of people may disappear from
the rat race machines will replace so
many jobs the drudgery of daily life may
be the struggle to find things to do
filling in the time utilizing our
leisure every car on the American Road
every new building the towers against
the sky is a sign of our progress
towards a better way of life we have a
comp
but the achievements to come will dwarf
our own the American Road stretches
ahead of it always towards a new horizon
we are all traveling along that road all
moving forward towards an even better
tomorrow
it's implied that this is part of an
inevitable progress that it's
automatically going to improve the
quality of our working lives that it is
progress in the widest sense of the word
that's going to lead to greater
prosperity and so on
turning battle it
we
program
after the Second World War the Americans
began a massive program of investment in
scientific research to come up with
lightweight computers for missile weapon
systems
out of this research was born a
revolutionary new technology the
computer on a silicon chip it was
cheaper faster and more reliable than
the first computer systems and big
companies rapidly recognized the
potential of micro electronics
throughout the 60s and 70s many
industries developed computer-controlled
production in Japan America and Europe
the big companies work towards the fully
automated factory serviced by automated
warehousing distribution and retail
systems please keep it quiet pseudo will
try to camera her
meanwhile back in Britain we are told of
the dire consequences if we do not
introduce these new technologies
countries which get in quickly on the
robot revolution will reap tremendous
rewards those who leg back will become
steadily less competitive and if we do
not invest in word processing and these
other areas in the way that I described
then we will not be competitive if we
don't move now and move very very
quickly both large and small companies
like I think we run a major risk of
losing competitiveness we still have
time to stay in this race if we run very
hard now they seem to be presenting it
as inevitable we cannot stop it we must
get in this race Britain must be in this
race or else we will be left behind you
know this race is already been won by
America in Japan I mean even if we join
this race Norway can we hope to keep up
with these people I forgot to join this
race at the moment there is a severe
crisis of profitability within
industries in in Western countries
they're having to put more and more
capital more and more people to extract
the same amount of profit from the
production process the Conservative
Political Center sees micro electronics
as the way out
they say the semiconductor revolution
offers a way out at the multiple crises
we face Lord Spence
in the House of Lords explains why
silicon chips do not belong to unions
they do not go on strike they do not ask
for more and more pay they do not need
holidays nor heated offices nor tea
breaks they are very reliable and do not
make mistakes they need very little
space in which to function they are very
cheap they use very little energy and
they are here now waiting to be brought
into use we are now in a period in which
production itself is being reorganized
to bypass to squeeze out labour from the
product
process whether its production on a
factory whether it's in an office and
micro electronics is a key technology at
the moment to enable the capitalists to
squeeze out or to regiment labor much
more they're eliminating human energy
and human intelligence by machines and
the reason they do this is they believe
that by reducing labor costs that is the
wages that are paid to the workers that
will render their industry more
efficient in the United States today
productivity it has become the status of
almost a major ideological war
management raises the flag of increased
productivity the workforce is supposed
to salute very often the question
however is not productivity but one of
control that is management would like to
observe increased control over the
workforce in the long run to maximize
profit well that's it's plain to see
less means productivity
you must be crazy you disagree with
profitability in the automobile industry
in the United States the Society of
manufacturing engineers predicted that
in the building of automobiles by 1985
one out of every five jobs would be
replaced in the direct assembly of a car
by robots and they went on to say that
by 1995 one out of every two jobs would
be replaced by robots take a bow t3 here
Cincinnati Milla kromm a robot
manufacturer explained in their
publicity film why robots are so
attractive for their customers in the
car industry you don't need to write any
programs punch tapes or perform complex
calculations all you do is use the
handheld teach pendants you see here to
guide the robot from point to point it
performs the most repetitive monotonous
tasks day in day out without complaint
never tires never needs a break it's
never absent and based on a two-year
payback three shifts a day
it works for about six dollars an hour
no fringes and to tell the robot what to
do at a particular point you just use
the alphanumeric keyboard shown here
it's a deliberate design of machines and
systems to remove decision-making from
the worker and to transfer it to another
point in the organization where it's far
more easily controlled the idea is to
take a job
where formerly a worker may have had
quite a bit of discretion in the timing
of the job for example a job done in a
bench where you have a lot of different
parts and you build a sub assembly this
job is then put on a transfer line where
workers and robots are alternated so all
of a sudden you find that your workmates
on either side and across from you are
robots but if the problem is more than
one of just not having anyone to talk to
you may begin to talk to the robots
after a point the problem becomes one of
the pace of work is set by the
mechanical arms on either side these
arms are programmed at a central methods
laboratory by Time study engineers so
work where you formerly had some control
over the pace or the method of operation
those decisions are completely removed
and you find yourself literally trapped
between mechanical arms program by
someone else you might ask why are there
people there in the first place and
that's strictly an economic decision
right now because the site and field for
robots haven't been perfected to the
point where this is economically
feasible right now so that's the sole
worth of a human being in the system
but it's not only engineering industries
that new technology manufacturers have
their eyes on information businesses
received by all kinds of equipment have
been required to manage it until now now
with Wang's new integrated information
system one person very simply can
perform data processing word processing
high-speed image printing and worldwide
communication if wine can create office
today who knows what the future holds
well the future for a lot of office
workers looks very uncertain because one
of the main targets of new technology is
the office a present about a quarter of
the American workforce work in offices
and half of the entire workforce work in
handling information in some form or
other during the 1970s US industrial
productivity rose ninety percent while
office productivity rose Amiga four
percent that's mainly because at present
they invest over twelve times as much an
industrial machinery as they do in
office machinery but the big companies
plan to change that by automating the
information industry as this Xerox film
explains let us begin our inquiry with
technology it's all here right now and
functioning usefully for Xerox customers
document creation given new speed in
sophistication high speed copying high
speed printing document transmission
electronic storage and retrieval digital
and image and more much more
impressive if the technology is here can
the system be far behind the main reason
why micro electronics is affecting the
office area is because it's a very labor
intensive area of work and most
management's regard this labor as
unnecessary and expendable and would
dearly like to get rid of it if they
could because it doesn't seem to be
productive
thank you offices represents a main
source of employment for women so that
in fact two out of five of all wage
women work in offices at the present
time and it's those jobs which are
likely to be hid and as far as estimates
are concerned it seems likely that it's
about a third of all clerical and
administrative jobs are likely to be
automated by the introduction of word
processors a French government report
also predicts that 30% of banking and
insurance jobs will go while in Germany
and Britain it's estimated that roughly
a third of all office jobs will be cut
within the next 10 years another
important reason why management is
introducing this equipment quickly is
because it increases management control
in fact some of the companies that sell
word processors actually say that it's a
useful tool for increasing management
control not just the time the people
spend in the equipment but also their
responsibility and discretion which is a
very human factor in offices Franco
DeBenedetti Joint Managing Director of
Olivetti says information technology is
basically a technology of coordination
and control of the labour force a factor
of fundamental importance in mechanizing
structured work is the capacity for
control that the manager thus acquires
William F Laughlin the vice president of
IBM puts it more bluntly people will
adapt nicely to office systems if their
arms are broken and we're in the
twisting stage now
companies are trying to increase the
amount of time spent on expensive
equipment because although this
equipment is very very cheap as
computers go it's better than a
typewriter and therefore if it's dearer
than a typewriter the whole of the
management idea is to keep you on the
machine for as long as possible as many
hours as possible the controlling very
very expensive systems which are getting
obsolete at an ever-increasing rate so
employers will seek to exploit that
equipment for 24 hours a day so they get
the maximum return before it's obsolete
and this is meant that by color workers
who never previously were pressurized to
accept shift working are now being
required to do so
good morning organization may I have
your merchant number social isolation is
also a complaint because you don't need
to be supervised by humans a lot of the
time you can make an error it's
automatically thrown up by the software
and therefore people are complaining
also social isolation but they actually
separate apart from the rest of the
operations in the business
office work is going to become
increasingly more and more like factory
work and that management by using word
processors will be able to exert greater
control over how the word processor
operator works we have the idea that
suddenly instead of doing all the boring
jobs and there's an awful lot of routine
number crunching and boring work on
computers as well and on WordPress but
instead of doing that now that we'll all
sit back and be doing fascinating
interesting responsible jobs simply
isn't true when my experience is that
this type of technology doesn't liberate
people at all that in fact the reverse
is the case it controls the whole
environment in which they work and
operate in the field of white-collar
work for example there are
computer-aided design system for
architects for the architects can no
longer think of all the type of
architectural elements they might use
but whether confronted almost like
children with a Lego set they can make a
pleasing pattern out of a few little
elements but they can't change the
elements because they're said to have
been optimized I think the whole history
of automation shows clearly that you can
remove routine work and at the same time
making the job that remains far more
monotonous the five interesting methods
job that went before it seems to me that
the jobs that remain whether the high
colour or in the manual field will be d
skilled there be jobs in which the
worker for the by hander by brain is
controlled by the machine rather than
the other way around that they'd be
reduced to almost a machine appendage
simply reacting to the system rather
than acting upon it and it will give the
employers enormous control over them
Oh
whoa
of the time production line
Oh
in each case where a new technology
emerges if you like from the laboratory
the the first question to ask is a
political question namely for what
purposes is this technology to be used
new technologies that allow you to shred
labor could create a situation where the
people who own the factories where
they're being applied can make an
enormous profit with fewer people who
all write a better paid but the real
price is paid by society because the
people who are displaced by the new
technology become unemployed they have
to be paid for out of the taxation and
society then moves towards the social
disruption that comes from higher
technology the prospect of a long term
dramatic increase in unemployment is
predicted in three recent reports Sussex
University estimate that by the end of
the 80s unemployment will rise to 3.4
million Cambridge economic policy group
estimate 4.6 million and as Tim's
estimate 5.2 million but there are those
who think this anxiety is mistaken I do
totally disagree with the whole thesis
that we're heading for 6 million
unemployed I think it's rubbish I think
it's rubbish and I think it's dangerous
talk to give people the idea that
there's any base in reality for that if
we behave sensibly those who behave
sensibly accept their own unemployment
as the price for higher productivity and
profitability for the big companies what
I only wish we could persuade the trade
unions to accept is that higher
productivity is the friend of full
employment but many organisations in
Britain and abroad have their doubts
about this and have brought out reports
examining the long-term implications of
new technology in the past we've seen
slumps but the danger today is not
cyclical unemployment as a result of a
slump but built-in structural
unemployment as a result of a radical
change in the industry in terms of the
technology used
in the past when the workers have been
replaced by the machines it's been
limited to a certain sector of the
economy for example in the 19th century
in the United States the farm was
mechanized but at the same time workers
were drawn into industry in the late 40s
and 50s when automation became popular
as a concept workers were displaced from
certain areas of the factory but at the
same time they were pulled into the
white-collar sector but today with the
microprocessor we're seeing a form of
technology that affects every productive
application of the society one very good
example of the lack of awareness on the
whole range of industries and services
they're going to be affected was shown
up in Bradford thorn electrics who make
color televisions and again they were
automating the way they make them and so
they had to layoff 2,000 women but they
decided that they would at least try and
retrain some of them so about 200 of
them have been retrained at a local
college at the expense of the manpower
Services Commission to be typists
because there's a lot of insurance
companies in Bradford and so you can
imagine the situation these women have
lost their job now been retrained proud
owners of a typing certificate marching
boldly to the new insurance company
doubtless to meet the women coming out
we've just been replaced by word
processors which have automated the work
that we've done surely there must be a
better way than then what is going on
because if Society this is just my
opinion if we go like we are doing we're
going to end up with an awful lot of
time in our hands and no money and
that's not funny
we have pieced together our model
community of the future a town which has
embraced technology wholeheartedly and
taken full advantage of all it has to
offer
and leisure is something in which
everyone in our community will be
encouraged to get involved a leisure
complex in every town containing craft
shops sports facilities entertainment
centers and hotels we will create a much
more humanistic society because
basically all the hard work that needed
to be done to keep our bodies alive
I'll be done by the robots if the robots
can do the work for us while we lie
around in the Sun why not let them all
of these nice little suggestions have
one big problem how do you pay for them
all this stuff about leisure or
increased education or whatever is
absolutely meaningless given up the
present way our society is organized
there is no mechanism for distributing
the wealth other than through the wage
and like if people are outside that way
struggling they even got anything it
doesn't just get shared out we don't all
get richer without some definite
intervention to try and distribute the
wealth and there's absolutely no sign
there's any thought or intent to do that
it's all right
talking about wage we talk about ways
you know but where's it to me it unless
you've got money to enjoy leisure
it's just force forced idleness
it's a brand new crisis with information
it's a movie it's an overnight sensation
all the guys and gals are doing it
um every way to put my name down
ah
the rise in unemployment over the last
five six years particularly the
acceleration of Britain's decline as an
economic power and all that is gone with
it have meant that there is a degree of
fatalism in the trade union movement I
think on a scale which which hasn't
existed since since the 1930s people
people that you don't expect to accept
redundancies let a fight are pending
this at back and accept redundancies
right I think it's very important not to
totally believe all the doom and gloom
because this implies if one accepts mass
unemployment is inevitable it implies
but nobody is able to control either the
society or indeed even their individual
workplace if we once allow the
complexity of technology to be used as
an excuse for not retaining democratic
control then a huge and growing chunk of
our future is obstructed from democratic
control and then you move towards a
technocratic domination of society which
is one of the real dangers that science
which began as the liberator of man
could end up enslaving man by putting
its power at the disposal of those who
already own our factories or own our
newspapers our televisions stations and
in this way impose a tyranny in the
guise of liberation
we got word processors we've got
point-of-sale systems in retail shops
with a little mini computers off on the
production line we've got big mainframes
gathering information and have
processing information for certain
companies the large multinationals for
instance we've got all these different
applications of micro electronics and
the problems is becoming how you knit
them all together because fundamentally
the micro electronics is being
introduced
so the multinationals can organize
they're very diversified empires their
empires that are spread all over the
globe one at the same time so that
they're able to know what happens at
their production plant in Hong Kong and
they're able to know in their New York
headquarters as it happens when we have
word processing systems or office
systems or data processing systems
linked together in different towns and
cities and countries by
telecommunication systems it'll be
possible as there is a strike say in
London that management could transmit
the work by the telecommunication system
to say Edinburgh the ability to run a
plant while workers are in strike is
also a very real danger this is as a
result of the design of technology to
minimize the need for skill or for human
experience this occurred at the
Washington Post in the middle 70s where
management issued a series of ultimatums
to the Union precipitated a strike and
then was able to destroy the Pressman's
Union through the ability to operate the
plant while with Pressman we're on
strike for close to four months in
America this is now known as Electronics
calving but to scalp electronically you
have to control the communication
networks the driving force behind the
convergence of these technologies is
increased control for the major
multinationals and they themselves are
fighting about who is going to control
these networks as they're set up the
battles are going to become quite
literally across the whole of the
Western world out of that battle you'll
emerge one or at the most to
corporations who will between them have
control of what will in the future be a
major means of handling information and
then we'll be in a position where a
primary life source is controlled by one
corporation with enormous profits with
very few people and it is able to call
the tune for what future developments
are
down in Silicon Valley
it's the Wild West all over
Salva me
discouraging words there's no one
say
we've got the Khan
got about a hard-working girl yesterday
we won the West
tomorrow we'll win the world
international control
that's what wage
control of banking and business dating
systems automated manufacture systems
stock storage and retail systems
protests entertaining systems state
surveillance and weapon systems control
satellite telecommunication system
Plutarco whole little package
international paltrow
that's our plan
we did it - and now we like to do it
one of the remarkable problems for the
employer about this kind of equipment is
whilst on the one hand it gives him or
her a great controller of the employees
on the other hand it is a fact that the
more you synchronize something and
capitalize it the more vulnerable it
becomes so now is the case that six
designers can go and strike and stop a
whole factory because the producing not
drawings would America controlled tapes
and in the past when they went on strike
they leave down the pencil and the
rubber nobody knew they were gone for
six weeks
it's now immediate yet companies are
planning to overcome this according to
the Institute of Directors in many
larger organizations today dependence on
computer systems has reached the stage
where the absence of a handful of
computer operators can bring much of the
business to a standstill
safeguards against this can never be
complete and must vary from case to case
but it is a problem which management
have to face when planning new systems
systems the solution or the problem this
is a problem that one American
multinational Xerox has already faced
anxious that their workforce might not
greet new technology with unbridled
optimism they have produced this
management training film to forestall
possible problems it's called the
Luddite factor James Watt invented an
interesting toy the system created the
Industrial Revolution not without
opposition the new machines eliminated
old skills
England organized bands known as
Luddites smashed by hated machines and
rioted to no avail their only legacy is
their name
blood ice the resistance to change overt
or otherwise the Luddite factor is
indeed tenacious like the earlier
Luddite
there is an impulse to turn against the
new technology to strike back and yet
for most business organizations it's not
a matter of whether but when frightening
off resistance by labeling it Luddite is
not only limited to company promotional
films the same message creeps into
television documentaries - trade unions
are shown as deeply suspicious of change
with their roots firmly entrenched in
the past in the early 19th century the
Luddites set out to destroy the machines
which they thought would put them out of
work it was just the first manifestation
of a general suspicion of technological
innovation and change but was Luddism
just a blinkered suspicion of
technological change or was something
greater at stake and just how different
was the position of the Luddite - the
situation today I think the most obvious
parallel between the introduction of
this type of technology and earlier ones
has been the distilling of skilled
craftsmen about 150 or 100 years ago for
the knowledge that existed in the worker
him or herself their ability to deal
with a whole range of complex problems
was gradually taken away from them and
embodied in machines like lathes milling
machines and so on and that reaches its
highest level in Uemura control machine
tools
we're completely d skilled workers do
work that previously would have been
done by highly skilled worker and I
think we're now beginning to see
repeated in the field of intellectual
work the kind of d skilling that we
sought an earlier historical stage in
the field of skill manual work and that
brought enormous suffering in my view
and a whole range of other problems and
far from learning from those problems we
seem determined to repeat them now in
the field of intellectual or
white-collar work although the air is
thick
debate with the microprocessor firmly at
the center of the stage the debate
itself is really already pointless today
our world is depending more and more on
computer technology and for some time
now we've been moving down a path from
which there's no turning back
is he right is the process of
technological change simply inevitable
and one over which there is to be no
control the only way to effectively deal
with microprocessor technology and use
it in a positive way is to be able to
propose not only did to have to say no
to the introduction of equipment but to
be able to have an input into the design
in deployment and use of the technology
itself technology was made by human
beings and if it's not doing first what
we want then we have a right and a
responsibility to change it it's not
given it's not like the Sun or the moon
or the Stars
because designed by people and we could
design it differently and I think this
is where people have got to have
confidence that even though they may not
be a PhD in nuclear physics they have
the authority the right to say to the
man who's got a device all right it's
interesting and thank you very much but
whether we apply it or not is a
political choice between your idea and
other options we've got to understand
that we do have a right to control the
technology but when you begin to try to
exercise that control invariably
it is rooted in the large multinational
corporations where that is the case if
effective resistance is built up in one
country they can move it to another and
in any case they frequently move it to
where labor costs are lowest or where
the workforce is most dohsa so I think
there's a massive job to be done in
terms of international trade union
solidarity
one workforce that has responded
internationally are the workers of the
Ford Motor Company one of the most
global of all the multinational
companies in November 1980 trade union
delegates from all Ford plants worldwide
met for the first time in Valencia Spain
the objective to formulate a common
strategy for bargaining with a company
who traditionally have played one
workforce off against another the
recently launched Ford Escort has been
heralded as a world car but for Ford
workers a world car means a world
production line with jobs components and
cars being shunted from one part of the
world to another
seriously undermining national trade
union bargaining power delegates pledges
it in future local disputes wherever
they occur would be supported on an
international level Ron's heart
transport in China workers union Ron
Todd chairman of the UK Ford negotiating
committee has no doubts about the
usefulness of this initiative there is a
greater need now for the workers of
Ford's across the world to get together
to coordinate our activities to exchange
our views on how we see the company
operating across the world now even more
than ever is there a need for that the
most important aspect of the Ford
conference was that it challenged the
whole concept of national
competitiveness but it was clear that
more issues United them then divided
them but challenging the idea that
nations must compete with each other is
not easy this is going to sound very
selfish but to think to most Ammar women
while they're in the struggle
fighting for the wrong survival it's
very difficult for them really to think
of somebody in Asia fighting for their
survival I can understand this but it
doesn't help because the struggle of the
women in Asia is part of our struggle
it's possible to design equipment which
is what I would call human centered that
is to say that we regard human skill
ability creativity and sheer enthusiasm
has asset rather than liability and we
designed the equipment around that
rather than seeking to use the
meant to diminish and control it so the
real options but it seems to me the
options are not so much technological
questions as political and ideological
ones what kind of society do we want how
do we want people to relate to
production and each other and when we
get that clear then we can design
equipment which will allow them to do
that I think the sense of the technology
should give people that this is the
moment when choices are to be made
rather than this is the moment where you
must buckle down and accept the
inevitable this is the key question and
if you can get that straight then the
introduction or the discovery of micro
electronics or any other new technology
gives people a sense of freedom